we really want to introduce Chinese
culture to American but with respect
of American culture to Peggy Cheung is
perhaps the most financially successful
woman to ever serve up Chinese culture
or American tastes she and her husband
Andrew are billionaires as the co-ceos
of their privately held restaurant chain
Panda Express as Chinese immigrants
they've always known their market we
tend to understand their American
Paladin on let's hope performing with
everything people
oh no bones no boss yeah which means
serving food that falls into this long
long history of westernizing traditional
Chinese food so it costs al American
Chinese food their latest American
Chinese dish is General Tso's chicken
but what's far more interesting here is
that even though Peggy's a self-made
billionaire she never dreamed of being a
restauranteur how did you come to be
running a restaurant group I was always
saying that I'm married to him he was
born in Burma and grew up in Hong Kong
she moved to the US for university which
is where she met Andrew also an
immigrant Panda Express actually started
as a sit-down restaurant panda in which
and reopened with his father who was a
master chef at a crucial turning point
in Chinese US history we open pending in
1973 our first restaurant in Pasadena
this year their President Johnson
visit China my second was President
Nixon Oh President Lee I'm sorry
president listen yeah which explains
where they got the name panda bear
become a symbol of friendship between US
and China they're cunning animal
friendly adorable
we'd lucky able to tip that into as odd
name by the early 80s malls were
expanding across America an Andrew saw
an opportunity to turn his sit-down
restaurant into a fast-food concept but
he couldn't build it alone he needed
Peggy who at that time was pursuing a
career far away from the world of
fortune cookies actually I was working
at the aerospace company
luckily for Panda Peggy's engineering
skills turned out to be the secret
ingredient to go from one restaurant too
many hey he left her job in aerospace to
scale Panda Express every 100 stall mark
is a huge change boss then you really
need structure a uni system but building
panda had its sacrifices was it easy for
you to leave a career in engineering no
I always still saying to myself that I
love to be inventor something nothing's
easy but I think all the time how
dedicate you are why were you so
dedicated then that's a tough question I
think a special engineer we're trying to
get everything done in the best way we
can